(paddle drum beat)
- This kind of exhibition
is really unique,
the public will see something
they never saw before,
and I hope they will like it
and I hope they will
really have the different
and change opinion about performance art.
So the preparation for the
MoMA show, it's going well.
I mean, it's a very big task for me
because it's not just third perspective
of my performers' work,
it's what really stands for
some kind of historical view,
what performers can be,
and how the performers
can enter the museum,
and how can be performers
collected from the museum,
and what happen if a performer die,
if the work can be
re-performed, can be continue,
and what kind of roles that will take.
It's really interesting
to see how the performers can be present
in the museum, live.
The title of the show is Marina
Abramović Artist is Present.
Literally, I will be there
for entire period of time
of three months and the
duration of the opening
of the museum, which means
seven and a half hours
of every day.
Also, there will be re-performance
of five of my performances,
some of which I made
in seventies and eighties,
and they're going
to re-perform the same amount
of time, like three months.
So this kind of thing's
never been done til now,
so it's a really big experiment.
I myself never actually
performed three months also.
If at my opening, and my
opening come only the artists
of my generation, I know of
something's terribly wrong,
because it means that my work
doesn't communicate anywhere,
that means it's dead.
There was a very funny
interview of Leonard Cohen,
and he say, "I am now in a third act,"
and in third act,
everything start very well,
but in the end, the main actor die.
I also feel that I'm in a
kind of third act right now,
you know, (mumbing) MoMA,
it's finishing a huge amount
of work, which is very
interesting about legacy,
what you going to leave after you die.
But one thing you can leave
always is a good idea,
and I really wanted to have
this good idea to live after me.